imagina que eres un estudiante de física
acabas de salir de clase vas caminando
hacia tu casa cuando recuerdas que hay
un maratón de guerra estelar hoy en la
noche así que haces lo que cualquier
estudiante de física haría correr estás
muy motivado para llegar a casa y
digamos que comienzas a correr a 6
metros por segundo y digamos que ella
tiene bastante tiempo desde la última
vez que corriste por lo que después de
cierto tiempo bajas la velocidad a dos
metros por segundo y cuando te acercas
más a casa dices no el capitán antares
no se rinde y yo tampoco me voy a rendir
y comienzas a correr a ocho metros por
segundo y llegas a casa justo a tiempo
para ver los créditos de inicio estos
números son valores de la rapidez
instantánea la rápida es instantánea es
la rapidez en un momento particular del
tiempo y si incluimos la dirección con
esta rapidez tendremos la velocidad
instantánea que es la velocidad en un
instante particular del tiempo
en otras palabras ocho metros por
segundo a la derecha
fue la velocidad instantánea de esta
persona en ese momento particular del
tiempo y noten que esto es diferente de
la velocidad promedio si tu casa se
encontraba a 1000 metros de distancia de
la escuela y te llevó un total de 200
segundos llegará ahí la velocidad
promedio será 5 metros por segundo la
cual no es necesariamente igual a la
velocidad instantánea en momentos
particulares de tu recorrido digamos que
tú corres una distancia de 60 metros en
un intervalo de tiempo de 15 segundos
durante este tiempo aceleras t de manera
que tu velocidad cambio en cada momento
sin importar el acelerar al principio o
frenar al final la velocidad promedio va
a seguir siendo de 4 metros por segundo
a la derecha o si gustan 4 metros por
segundo positivo
digamos que ustedes quieren saber la
velocidad instantánea en un momento
particular de su recorrido en este caso
queremos encontrar el menor
desplazamiento entre el intervalo de
tiempo más pequeño centrado en ese
momento en donde queremos encontrar la
velocidad instantánea esto nos dará un
mejor valor para la velocidad
instantánea pero no nos va a dar el
valor exacto para encontrar la velocidad
en este instante podemos encontrar un
desplazamiento a uno es pequeño y
dividirlo entre un intervalo de tiempo
mucho más pequeño pero aquí nos vamos a
encontrar con un problema si queremos
encontrar la velocidad instantánea
exacta deberemos tomar un desplazamiento
infinitesimalmente pequeño dividido
entre un intervalo de tiempo
infinitesimalmente pequeño también pero
esto es básicamente cero entre cero y
durante mucho tiempo nadie pudo
encontrarle el sentido a esto si hay que
definir el movimiento en uno
de particular del tiempo parecía
imposible hizo que algunos sabios
griegos de la antigüedad se cuestionarán
si es que el movimiento tenía algún
significado se preguntaban si es que el
movimiento era tan sólo una ilusión
eventualmente sí isaac newton desarrolló
todo un nuevo método de hacer
matemáticas que nos permitían encontrar
respuestas a este tipo de preguntas hoy
le llamamos a la matemática que inventó
newton cálculo así que si le
preguntáramos a un físico cuál es la
fórmula para la velocidad instantánea él
o ella probablemente nos mostrarían una
fórmula que involucra cálculo pero en el
caso de que alguno de ustedes aún no
haya tomado estas clases de cálculo les
voy a mostrar algunas formas de
encontrar la velocidad instantánea que
no requieren usar cálculo la primera
forma es tan simple que parece obvia si
tienen la suficiente suerte como para
tener un caso en donde la velocidad de
un objeto no cambia entonces la fórmula
de la velocidad promedio
dar el mismo número que la velocidad
instantánea en cualquier punto del
tiempo si nuestra velocidad está
cambiando una forma de encontrar la
velocidad instantánea es ver al
movimiento en una gráfica x contra t la
pendiente en cualquier punto particular
de la curva de esta gráfica de posición
contra tiempo va a ser igual a la
velocidad instantánea en ese punto en el
tiempo ya que la pendiente nos va a dar
la tasa instantánea del cambio en x con
respecto al cambio en t otra forma de
encontrar la velocidad instantánea es
para que el caso especial en donde
tenemos una aceleración constante si la
aceleración es constante podemos usar
las fórmulas cinemáticas para encontrar
la velocidad instantánea b para
cualquier tiempo t